[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with foreign affairs writer tim marshall
and the daily telegraph chief political
correspondent chris hope
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages now and as you might imagine
the taliban takeover of afghanistan is
the lead for many
the fall of cardball that's the headline
in the metro which pictures helicopters
taking staff from the u.s embassy in
kabul a way to safety as the taliban
arrives in the city
the telegraph shows the evacuation from
the ground with the headline the west
flees as kabul falls to taliban
this is the front of the sun escape from
kabul
the financial times taliban on brink of
taking over afghanistan as president
flees
the socialist mourning star under the
headline kabul falls says britain and
the us are being blamed by anti-war
campaigners for a failed military
intervention that should never have
started in the first place
one view from abroad the leading german
daily frankfurter algamina zidman says
the taliban is ready for the transition
of power in kabul with the afghan
president having fled and the german air
force about to leave too
while the star looks elsewhere and leads
with an impending heat wave on its way
to the uk from spain
well i'm joined tonight by foreign
affairs writer tim marshall and the
daily telegraph chief political
correspondent chris hope welcome to you
both good evening let's start with the
daily telegraph and first of all in
their headline the west flees as kabul
falls to taliban uh chris take us into
this write up
well as we'll see through this this
paper preview from tomorrow's papers
there really is a set of papers here
which does which will make sobering
reading in whitehall this is the west
figures kabul falls the taliban the
telegraph splash tomorrow morning it
talks about scenes reminiscent of the
evacuation of saigon at the end of the
vietnam war with the skies over kabul
full of u.s helicopters ferrying staff
from the u.s embassy it reports here the
u.s ambassador has left kabul clutching
the u.s flag the french ambassador also
left the uk ambassador laurie bristow is
still there he wants to see the
remaining diplomats evacuated safely um
we will come on to why this is happening
but it is such a rush and this this to
me
in a week when parliament is recalled on
wednesday this shows the beginning of
the return
to normal politics this kind of politics
is a politics which boris johnson will
be really tested on as prime minister
after this kind of 18 months of of of a
deep freeze while we've dealt with with
uh with the the dreadful virus
yes and the the article um saying that
the the prime minister boris johnson has
accepted there would be a change in the
afghan government but has called on
allies not to recognize the taliban's
reign um
does that surprise you
tim
no that they can't do that yet because
that's a carrot they're going to have to
hold out uh after this has played out i
mean the chinese may be the first to to
recognize taliban as i don't know about
the legitimate government but the
government um and i think that the the
many of the other countries
especially the democracies they just
need that as a carrot to try to get them
to have some uh
form of of liberalism is the wrong word
but you know what i mean treating the
population
decently as as they try to avoid it
falling back into another civil war but
the pay chris is right the the the
headlines are are devastating i think
not not the actual headlines criticizing
boris johnson just the overall tone and
the word failure that you're seeing in
the media over and over again i
particularly like the metro i'm sorry
and this is going to happen monday
tuesday and wednesday ahead of
parliament i like the metro front page
because chris mentioned the echo of
saigon and both the metro and the
morning star have that photograph and
that that up for me is going to be one
of the defining images uh over the next
few days
and um chris let's move on to the sun
their
front page escape from from car ball um
speaking to people tonight that the fear
is that the people in afghanistan do
feel abandoned and that international
troops are there to retrieve that their
own people but those without uh
international passports are left to to
cope with the taliban yeah
it's moved so quickly i mean just two
weeks ago i was reporting to the
telegraph how there's a big push to
bring back interpreters this is our
afghan interpreters who helped um allied
troops in afghanistan and now it's got
much wider i mean the pace of this i
think has caught everyone a bit
surprised uh by supplies and that's why
we have the cobra meeting uh today um
what this means the uk i don't know i'm
looking back at tweets by by um of the
ambassador who will be leaving the
country shortly for salary briscoe here
he said in a tweet back in just june as
recently as june he said the uk's
commitment to afghanistan remains as
strong as ever well that is completely
at odds with the headlines you're seeing
today and i wonder what the long-term
damage the uk might be in terms of the
way we're fleeing so quickly ben wallace
wrote in the sudden telegraph today the
defense secretary he said that we just
can't quote it alone the reality is we
cannot be on our on our own in
afghanistan we follow where the u.s goes
and i wonder whether that's that's the
the what we'll see throughout this week
looking into wednesday as tim says when
parliament's recalled um
will this uh lead to a reappraisal of
how much we are in the pocket of america
in terms of overseas uh military
adventures like this one
and tim what sort of long-term damage do
you see being done as a result of
uh well the initially the withdrawal of
the american troops uh and britain
also it is generational damage and you
can argue about the rights and wrongs of
going there in the first place the
rights wrongs about getting out you
can't argue about how how the manner of
getting out that is just an abject
failure
but whatever you think about it it's a
generational failure and i don't like
the term the west i prefer i think it's
a 20th century term i prefer
industrialized democracies but this is a
western issue
and the west has abjectly failed being
seen to fail why should any country
trust a western country uh just to stick
with it that the operation was called
enduring freedom that's not much of
an enduring freedom uh period so i i do
think it's generational and i do think
that the ramifications are going to be
with us for a long time now public
opinion though that that's that's
another matter um i think a lot of
people in this country just simply have
had enough of foreign adventures uh even
if it's going to lead to certain things
down the line
we've spoken about the metro front page
but in their letters page uh they're
they're talking about the the rush to to
quit and and what position that has left
the afghan people in tim
sorry chris i mean yeah i mean that
that's one of the reasons i brought that
up um
i mean these letters though are saying
it's a rotten rush and the afghans have
been betrayed and i think there will be
an awful lot of people who do think that
but you know the main fear doesn't
always
portray public opinion because the
american media are going down the same
line and i personally
feel this is a betrayal and a failure
but american public opinion
after a few months might just think well
i'm glad we're shot of that now i
personally think that this is going to
come back and buy us down the years with
heroin and refugees but it is a it's a
global problem
and very briefly
the defense secretary might say
um and this is something that the
frankfurter algominer is bringing up the
defense secretary might as well as the
americans go we have to go it's not
strictly true there's 27 other nato
countries can they really not pony up
two and a half thousand troops to fill
the gap that the americans did they all
said the americans are going we're off
chris what's your view on that and
public opinion
well i i think i think tim's right in
the short but i think you know like tim
said longer term there could be a real
problem here with refugees we you know
we know what happened pre 9 11 with that
with the with the
afghanistan and the rest i wonder how
much i mean joe biden
might really have a problem here i mean
obviously this decision was made by
donald trump who was reaffirmed by joe
biden when he became u.s president i
mean imagine if this was a trump
decision trump was in was in charge now
and the grief he'd be getting people say
that joe biden was different to trump
but in many ways
you could argue by setting an artificial
date of the 20th anniversary of 9 11 for
this to happen um and then to drive it
forward i mean he's almost looking
towards the midterms next year
getting this done dealing with this now
um and i wonder what happened this might
come back to haunt him yes uh to mark
his uh presidency chris antion for the
moment thank you uh coming up
meat eaters eat your heart out the vegan
menu is on the rise stay with us
[Music]
you are watching the press preview with
us tonight foreign affairs writer tim
marshall and the daily telegraph chief
political correspondent chris hope
welcome back to both of you and let's
have a look at the telegraph uh and this
is following on from the plymouth
shootings and it now seems that uh gun
owners are going to face scrutiny on
social media uh before being granted
licenses chris
yes i mean this of course is you know
the horse has bolted on this dreadful
tragedy but and um
the home office is now looking at the
the kind of social media comments from
all 720 000 people who have gun licenses
asking forces to look into it
um
you know it's about time given the kind
of file um which this man uh jake
davidson was pumping out online it's
extraordinary that he was giving back
his gun license um despite all the
threats he was making so i think it's um
it's about time and but it should have
been done before and it's so sad that
life's been lost yes and tim it does
seem um incredibly easy to to get a gun
license you wonder how a 22 year old got
a gun license in the first place had it
revoked and then returned
in theory it it it isn't but um in
practice it seems to be and so yeah i
mean i just agree with chris i agree
with chris that
you know it's a terrible wake-up call
but but clearly they have got to look
very closely at these stipulations to be
given the license
yes let's uh turn a corner now and just
a time for this
final story in the telegraph and this is
the
unstoppable rise of the vegan menu does
that does that upset or please either of
you chris
well it doesn't surprise me as a father
of teenagers i mean a lot of young
people are vegans nowadays i mean i
think um perhaps
me and tim might enjoy taking just steak
in a glass of clara of an evening but i
think it's right you know that people
are worried about particularly beef i
think beef is a big problem for young
people nowadays i think it's a bit cruel
the way cows are brought up and milk is
produced and the rest of it and i think
this you know i think it's interesting i
think also a lot of the vegan many taste
like meat
tim
we've come a long way since the nut
cutlet when only the people that went
into vegetarian restaurants they had
beards and sandals
and this is my only opportunity to say
again as a foreign affairs journalist
that i did not want to do this story but
the one from the frankfurter there's a
joke in there ah yes
we'll search for it too
thank you very much
thank you both we shall see you again